[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le 7-8 week-end
sur tv 78 actualité idées de sorties
pour bien terminer la semaine dans les
yvelines voici le programme de ce 28
janvier le chômage a largement reculé en
2021 dans le département - 9,7 pour cent
pour la catégorie a si bien que le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi est revenu
à un niveau similaire à celui d'avant la
crise sanitaire comment expliquer cette
diminution philippe combes directeur
territorial de pôle emploi yvelines est
notre invité les 17e aubin pia des
jeunes bergers la finale régionale de ce
concours national visant à valoriser le
métier d'éleveur de brebis se dérouler
ce vendredi c'était à la bergerie
nationale de rambouillet douze élèves
d'établissements agricoles étaient en
lice et puis comme tous les vendredis
nos idées de sorties dans les yvelines
pour samedi dimanche et dans les jours à
venir c'est à suivre dans la deuxième
partie de cette émission et ce sera bien
sûr comme d'habitude avec mon acolyte du
vendredi c'est bixente moyens santisteva
bonjour bixente jean grégory qui
m'accompagne tous les vendredis dans
cette émission même si à ma place à la
semaine dernière il y avait juste in
brazil qui a assuré le relais quel est
le programme du jour mais j'agis pas mal
de musique d'abord mon invité qui est un
chanteur il me reste qu'il viendra
parler de son concert est aussi du jazz
et ce sera tout à l'heure bien sûr dans
le 7-8 week end
[Musique]
le nous vous l'annoncions cette semaine
dans le journal tout comme au niveau
national le chômage a nettement baissé
en 2021 dans les yvelines - 9,7 pour
cent pour la catégorie à celle des
personnes sans activité un niveau un peu
moins fort qu'au niveau national à où la
baisse est de 12 % mais elle reste dans
une dynamique similaire et en décembre
2021 le département comptait 66 mille
600 demandeurs d'emploi de catégorie a
soit un niveau similaire de celui
d'avant la crise sanitaire on parle de
ces chiffres avec philippe quand qui est
avec nous par visioconférence bonjour
bonjour le directeur territorial de pôle
emploi dans les yvelines alors si on
regarde de plus près cette baisse est ce
qu'il ya une catégorie d'âge est ce
qu'il ya des secteurs de meetic sont
davantage concernés par par ce recul du
chômage alors sur la catégorie d'âge bas
principalement les jeunes donc pourquoi
pourquoi les jeunes ont été favorisées
sur 7 se baisse sur cette belle c'est
bâtir en lien aussi avec le plan un
jeune une solution qui a été mis en
oeuvre par par le gouvernement et donc
ces jeunes ont pu bénéficier de deux
formations ont pu bénéficier aussi de
contrat de contrats aidés le contrat
initiative emploi
qu'il aura largement bénéficié puisque
nous sommes sur une baisse sur la
catégorie
alors dans cette fois ci toute catégorie
a mais pour les jeunes sur une baisse de
12 3% en un an alors vous disiez le plan
un jeune une solution pour expliquer
cette baisse chez les jeunes et si on
regarde la tendance globale est ce qu'il
ya des des motifs d'explication déjà qui
se dégage pour expliquer justement cette
baisse je le rappelle -9 7% pour la
catégorie a en 2021 dans les yvelines la
principale explication c'est la reprise
économique sur sur un grand nombre de
secteurs et aujourd'hui nous avons sur
le département comme en ile de france un
certain nombre de secteurs qui
connaissent encore des détentions tel le
commerce la santé l'aide à la personne
le bâtiment le numérique tout ce qui
concerne aussi l'hôtellerie la
restauration l'industrie le transport et
la logistique
et puis un nouveau secteurs en tension
qui apparaît aussi c'est la sécurité
puisque on est à la veille
de la coupe du monde de rugby en 2023
sur notre région et puis les jeux
olympiques de paris 2024 et donc va y
avoir de fortes demandes en terme de
personnels de sécurité
dont je parlais tout à l'heure vous
disais oui on l'expliquent par la
reprise économique finalement on a vécu
une année 2020 avec de confinement il ya
eu un confinement beaucoup plus léger en
2021 une reprise des activités notamment
dans l'hôtellerie restauration ça
explique ce recul oui ça explique tout
appel tout à fait heureux que le recul
avait d'ailleurs les les entreprises ont
même du mal aujourd'hui à ce que je
disais par rapport à ces secteurs qui
sont en tension plus qu'elles ont du mal
à trouver de la main d'oeuvre il ya
aussi une 2 2 fait qu'une ni adéquation
entre entre l'offre et la demande et
tout le travail consiste aujourd'hui à
faire connaître ses métiers aux
demandeurs d'emploi et donc nous
organisons dans nos agences des rendez
vous entre les entreprises des
organismes de formation et les
demandeurs d'emploi pour leur faire
connaître le métier aujourd'hui on a
aussi une problématique sur le chômage
de longue durée voire de très longue
durée donc des personnes qui ont qui
sont installés depuis plus de deux ans
le chômage de très longue durée est en
augmentation et donc on est en train de
mettre en place un plan de re
mobilisation de ces demandeurs d'emploi
est effectivement de leur faire
connaître les métiers qui recrutent
aujourd'hui nous avons à notre
disposition de nombreuses formations sur
sex sur ces secteurs en tension est
d'ailleurs en 2021 vingt-six mille
demandeurs d'emploi ont pu bénéficier de
deux formations on voyait que la
formation est aussi un vecteur important
pour une reprise d'emploi et quand on
regarde le taux d'accès à l'emploi six
mois après la fin à la fin de formation
on est sur 51 7 % des demandeurs
d'emploi qui ont suivi une formation qui
ont retrouvé un emploi ceux des terres
une personne sur deux a pu retrouver un
emploi d'où l'importance de la formation
pour pouvoir répondre à la demande des
entreprises du département par rapport
aux offres qu'elles qu'elles diffusent
aujourd'hui et je le disais en début
d'entretien on est revenu à des niveaux
quasi similaire en tout cas des niveaux
on peut dire équivalent à ceux d'avant
crise sanitaire en terme de demandeurs
d'emploi est ce que ça veut dire que les
effets de la crise sanitaire sur
l'emploi ont été totalement annulée ou
c'est encore un peu trop tôt pour le
dire aujourd'hui on est sur un dépôt
d'offres qui est équivalent à celui de
2010 neuf donc on a récupéré le
l'ensemble des offres qui était diffusée
avant avant la crise et vous parler du
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi quand on
regarde au premier trimestre
2001 on était à 65 mille quatre cent dix
demandeurs d'emploi en catégorie a et
voyez aujourd'hui on a
66600 d'ailleurs question sur les
perspectives 2022 quelles sont-elles et
ce qu'elles sont plutôt bonne plutôt
positives sur cette année la reprise a
été soutenue en 2021 a priori l'asnl à
2022 s'annonce
de bonne augure aussi donc voilà
maintenant il faut trouver l'adéquation
entre l'offre et la demande et bien et
bien entendu faire connaître les métiers
qui recrutent aux demandeurs d'emploi
être capable aussi de leur donner des
perspectives d'évolution pour aussi les
attirer et faire en sorte qu'ils le
veulent bien prendre ces offres qui sont
aujourd'hui diffusées et vous le disais
notamment un secteur le secteur de la
sécurité un qui va avoir besoin de
recrutement des besoins de recrutement
avec deux événements majeurs la coupe du
monde de rugby en 2023 et aussi les jeux
olympiques 2024 qui vont arriver bien
sûr en france merci d'avoir été avec
nous philippe campent et mais il n'y a
pas de quoi en 30 journées à revoir
territorial de pôle emploi dans les
yvelines
cette finale des olympiades finale
régionale et on parlait il ya un instant
d'emploi et bien justement la filière
recherche des jeunes motivés un éleveur
de brebis sur 2 partira à la retraite
dans les prochaines années est les deux
candidats arrivés en tête pourront
concourir au titre de meilleur jeune
berger de france au salon de
l'agriculture de paris mathilde francon
ils sont une douzaine d'élèves de la
bergerie nationale à tenter de décrocher
les deux premières places de cette
finale régionale pour devenir meilleur
jeune berger d'île de france et leur
faut réussir les épreuves théoriques et
pratiques ces épreuves sont inspirés des
gestes quotidiens des éleveurs comme
criaient des brebis et évaluer leur état
de santé alors l'épreuve de santé ça
consiste à attraper le mouton à regarder
les dents à regarder les muqueuses
oculaires à regarder les pattes regardez
les mamelles
de façon à faire un diagnostic on va
dire chanter avec les éléments qu'on
voit une épreuve physique qui permet aux
élèves de vraiment rentrer dans le vif
du sujet je sais que je vais juste du
mal à les retourner mais si j'avais
peut-être plus de temps j'aurais réussi
mais du coup je me suis pressé ça m'a
fait ça se passe bien faut rester calme
parce que sinon les brebis parter un
petit peu dans tous les sens mais si on
reste calme et que on y va doucement ça
se passe très bien ces olympiades sont
aussi l'occasion pour les candidats de
rencontrer et d'échanger avec des
professionnels
c'est important de les former puis
surtout de leurs filets les bons tuyaux
l'histoire qui se découragent pas
donc c'est pour ça qu'on est c'est
plutôt agréable de leur transmettre des
choses ce qui est important pour nous
c'est de montrer que notre enseignement
est valorisable auprès des
professionnels puisque là ce sont
aujourd'hui des professionnels qui
jugent nos élèves sur des épreuves
pratiques
et qui normalement doivent montrer que
notre enseignement est directement
applicable sur le terrain la filière
ovine propose près de 10000 emplois
d'éleveurs dans la prochaine décennie
pour ces jeunes de 16 à 24 ans devenir
berger c'est avant tout être en lien
avec la nature et les animaux déjà c'est
l'éducation que j'ai reçu mon père était
berger j'ai un peu grandi avec les
chevaux la nature etc donc je voulais
partir là dedans dans la vie puis j'aime
bien les moutons quoi la proximité avec
la nature il ya plus de contact avec les
animaux je trouve en aux vaincus en
bovins et pour une femme qui veut
s'installer tout seul c'est bien plus
facile de manipuler un mouton de 70 kg
qu'une bâche de 500 kg quoi lauriane
conseil et manon baptista sont les
grandes gagnantes de cette finale
régionale
elles auront la chance de concourir au
titre de meilleur jeune berger de france
2022 lors de la finale nationale au
salon de l'agriculture de paris
le football-club de versailles face à
son destin pour la première fois de son
histoire le club joue les huitièmes de
finale de la coupe de france rencontre
ce samedi face à toulouse pensionnaire
de ligue au stadium de la ville rose
coup d'envoi 16h15 deux divisions
d'écart séparent les deux équipes le
match était initialement prévu à
versailles mais finalement est déplacé à
toulouse faute de stade nombre ont
homologué et dans les dernières heures
avant le rendez vous les hommes de
youssef chebbi vous le voyez ont pu
profiter des installations de
clairefontaine le centre de l'équipe de
france pour se préparer et les joueurs
et les dirigeants ont hâte d'en découdre
face à des footballeurs professionnels
écouter cette interview recueillie par
michael et demi d'euros il ya quelques
semaines bien sûr que c'est jouable mais
c'est un sacré challenge on essayait de
le relever on va essayer de poursuivre
l'aventuré on savait bien qu'à un moment
tombé sur un gros 1 le tirage au sort
nous a plutôt favorisé jusque là
puisqu'à parfois aussi qu'ils étaient
dans notre quête un autre championnat
toutes les autres tous les autres
adversaires étaient de divisions
inférieures bon et ça nous a déjà donné
du souci mais on est là bon on savait
qu'on tomberait sur un gros c'est
toulouse ça va pas être facile je suis
d'accord mais toulouse est aussi
concerné par la montée comme nous
toulouse pas toujours mis son équipe
type de championnat en coupe de france
donc on se dit que 1 toulouse comme nous
focaliser sur la montée qui joue pas
avec forcément sont son titulaire ça
peut peut-être est un toulouse qu'on peu
chahuté et qu'on va peut-être essayant
qu'on va essayer dans tous les cas de de
bousculer et ça c'est sûr qu'on va pas y
aller enfin aller dans ce match comme
des comme des victimes résignées non on
va jouer notre chance à fond toulouse
vers sa huitième de finale de la coupe
de france de football c'est ce samedi
coup d'envoi à 16 heures 15 le match est
diffusé sur eurosport allez versailles
c'est la fin de semaine et avant
d'aborder la suite et d'aborder le
week-end que faut-il retenir d actualité
dans les yvelines des derniers jours
céline charles vous résume le tout en 78
secondes
[Musique]
quel but poursuit sa transition
énergétique 41 nouveaux bus vont être
alimentés au biométhane attrape les
premiers bus pourraient circuler d'ici
la fin de l'année le centre de
vaccination de mantes-la-jolie va
déménager il fermera le 31 janvier et
devrait ouvrir le 3 février à
magnanville au complexe sportif firmin
riffaud
le rappeur kery james et les footballeur
nabil fekir et bryan dabo ont décidé
d'offrir une bourse de 12 mille euros
aux titulaires du baccalauréat qui
habite à trappes les inscriptions sont
ouverts jusqu'au dimanche 30 janvier à
minuit l'acteur yves binois samu ou tal
ben ali est nommé aux césars 2022 dans
la catégorie du meilleur espoir masculin
pour le film une histoire d'amour et de
désir de leïla ben bouzid
réponse le 25 février lors de la
cérémonie le latmos prépare le lancement
de son second nanosatellites inspire
sats est prévue en 2023 un an après
avoir lancé le premier il est
actuellement en phase d'assemblage et a
été présenté pour la première fois la
sixième édition de la semaine olympique
et paralympique se déroule jusqu'au 29
janvier à saint quentin en yvelines avec
comme objectif de faire découvrir les
trois sites olympiques saint quentinois
de nombreux ateliers sportifs sont
organisés à cette occasion
[Musique]
votre rubrique légal chez king à présent
pour vérifier ce que disent les acteurs
de l'actualité raphaël mata duvignau du
collectif des surligneurs et décrypte
aujourd'hui une proposition de campagne
d'anne hidalgo candidate socialiste à
l'élection présidentielle
hanine allemand souhaite promouvoir le
recours aux circuits courts garantissant
un accès à la qualité alimentaire tout
en développant l'agriculture locale elle
propose donc un chèque alimentation
durable pour acheter les produits sains
et locaux la démarche est louable mais
prévoir un système dérogatoire en
privilégiant et en favorisant le recours
à une agriculture locale est susceptible
d'entraver les règle fondatrice du
marché commun européen en effet qu au
regard de la jurisprudence de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne la mesure
proposée par la candidate socialiste
pourrait être illégale car elle restera
les échanges commerciaux entre les états
européens et porterait donc atteinte à
la libre circulation des marchandises
principe fondamental garanti par les
traités européens cependant ces mêmes
traité prévoit il est vrai des
dérogations à la libre circulation
des restrictions sont en effet possibles
si la mesure envisagée a pour objectif
sur la protection de la santé publique
sur la défense de l'environnement mais
en tout état de cause il est impossible
de recourir à ces mécanismes de
restrictions si la mesure vise
exclusivement la protection de
l'économie locale la proposition d'anne
hidalgo ne remplit pas les conditions
auxquelles puisqu'elle distingue entre
d'un côté les produits sains objectifs
de santé publique et de l'autre les
produits locaux objectif purement
économique hors local et sain ne vont
pas forcément ensemble d'autant que la
candidate se place clairement sur le
terrain du développement économique de
l'agriculture locale
par ailleurs pour ouvrir l'accès local
aux circuits courts il faudra mettre en
avant des motivations environnementales
et pas seulement viser les producteurs
locaux or on le sait aussi production
locale et protection de l'environnement
ne vont pas systématiquement ans en
couple une autre difficulté se présente
année dalo comment définir sa et locales
un produit issu de l'agriculture
allemande est il moins cinq ans il vient
d'alsace ou de même un produit provenant
d'un village frontalier espagnol et il
voit un local que s'il vient d'une
commune française située à 80 90 km on
le voit beaucoup d'obstacles normatif se
présentent à la maire de paris le
bonheur électorales et peut être dans le
pré mais cette proposition est pour le
moment trop verte et il faut encore
l'amour et le terrain juridique pour la
rendre conforme notamment au droit
européen
allez c'est l'heure de sortir à présent
dans les yvelines
et on retrouve bien sûr bixente mais un
centriste est bonne on on débute cette
partie idées de sorties avec votre
invité bixente en effet grégory
aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
olivier delafosse plus connu sous le nom
d'oldelaf qui viendra se produire demain
soir samedi 29 janvier à 20 heures au
théâtre de la nacelle à aubergenville
bonjour al de l'afld bonjour je suis
ravi d'être là oldelaf vous présenterez
du coup pour ce concert de nombreux
morceaux notamment ceux de votre
nouvelles pelles aventure continue la
suite de votre album laventure dans
cette paix on retrouve par exemple son
demi dieu que vous avez clip et
récemment voici un petit extrait on voit
tomber des boues des toiles à croire que
le ciel est abîmée
[Musique]
et
oh
et tous
[Musique]
bon l'homme n'est qu'à moitié heureux
mais j'espère que demain vos spectateurs
à aubergenville le seront complètement
et pour qu'il le soit qu'est ce que vous
leur avez concocté qu'est-ce que vous
laverez leur avait préparé un moment
historique je pense qu'on va se
rapprocher du live the dream de martin
luther king ce soit des moments qui ont
marqué l'histoire aubergenville va ce
nombre les gens voient évidemment
ouvertes et par millions milliards
peut-être revoir ce spectacle évidemment
tu pourras pas fait rentrer à tout le
monde mais quand on est pour les gens
les chanceux qui seront dans la salle
save est extraordinaire parce qu'on va
tout donner by avoir la foi de l'émotion
va y avoir
des moments de fraternité
et je pense que même si mal et masque on
s'embrasse sur la bouche
il y aura du coup les deux albums enfin
l'aventuré laventure continuer ce qu'on
aura le droit aussi à vos classiques oui
un petit peu vous savez les gens les
gens me supplient les gens les ans rêve
de tous ses tubes que j'avais plus
experts de pardon mon histoire chargée
histoires
graves et des souvenirs dans
l'inconscient collectif voilà et je
jouerai des changes comme la tristesse
avait des moments incroyables la
tristitude les mains froides après des
années après des années de chansons
humoristiques et de concerts vous n'êtes
toujours pas fatigué vous êtes toujours
animé par cette passion l'amène envie de
retourner sur scène
j'avoue que c'est un tout qui
font que je monte sur scène partager des
choses avec les gens et c'est vrai que
c'est ce que je me bats pour ça mais ça
a été dur à l'aide habitants les deux
mêmes même là ça va être
ce sont des moments qui sont de plus en
plus précieuses de la façon oui c'est ce
que vous dénoncez un peu avec le p
laventure continue c'est ça c'est cette
difficulté aujourd'hui avec le covin
notamment bah oui alors la vente au
continu assez on est beaucoup sur le
voyage le thème c'est le voyage fut l
aventure c'est un album qui parle et ne
voyagez en titre voyage donc l'aventuré
continue en revanche le morceau de
milieux lui parle des des masques qui
ils sont peut-être nécessaire parfois je
ne me positionne pas par rapport à ça
mais ils font des frontières entre les
en est et qui font ce choix n'est qu'à
moitié on a un petit peu joué avec notre
paradis et là où on s'en mord les doigts
et quelle est la chanson que vous
préférez interprété sur scène et ce
qu'il y en a une en particulier la
zoubida mais ça n'a rien à voir avec mes
enfants et la julia c'est
comme un hymne national non pas du tout
hein or dans mes chansons à
jo bats les jeunes a plusieurs qu'il y
en a une en ce moment qui n'est pas de
seins coniques s'appelle voulait clown
ça me fait vrai jeu je crois vraiment
monter quand on la chante mais c'est une
chanson inconnue aller il faut venir la
découvrir sur scène vraiment c'est un
moment on a du mal à l'accepter
alors j'ai une connaissance qui quand
elle était jeune écouter les chats
karatékas est ce que vous le voulez
chanter toujours sur scène c'est vieux
mais alors ça c'est pour les enfants on
le chante quand on fait quelques
spectacles faisant ça serra n'a pas
après tour mais ça depuis un petit
moment mais c'est une chanson vraiment
pour les enfants 2007 et du ca du rock
du huard pour les enfants c'est quoi
mais on l'a fait pour toi val de lawe si
vous le voulez bien rester deux petites
minutes avec nous puisque d'autres
humoristes se rendront prochainement
dans les yvelines ces prochaines
semaines voici notre top des one man
show à venir avec il me semble en ami à
voile de la regarder
[Musique]
oh
j'ai croisé un écolier ya pas longtemps
on sait pas parler longtemps parce qu'il
s'est mis à pleuvoir et il sait toucher
mais
bon gars bon gars mais il m'a un peu
énervé
[Musique]
où
c'est un peu flippant arrivera un jour
ici d'être un jour tu partiras chez ami
après un dîner du retard dans ses
fichiers
avec leurs engins compris le club perd à
chaque fois je mets leurs deux
hommes et deux étoiles voilà au prévenir
tout le monde
[Musique]
alors ils doivent comment trouvez-vous
ce programme me semble que vous
connaissez pierre emmanuel bach est
notamment
le seul que je pars au contraire si
haroun mais aussi vous avez un très beau
programme dans les yvelines lâchant
allez voir que ce spectacle absolument
sûr merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
je le rappelle d'aller voir d'abord veut
le spectacle que vous produirez demain
samedi 29 janvier au théâtre de la
nacelle à aubergenville et poisseux pour
ceux qui ne pourront pas vous voir ce
week-end d'ailleurs pas de panique
puisque vous reviendrez aussi dans les
yvelines à la mjc de la
celle-saint-cloud plus précisément le 21
mai prochain
tout à fait balayer ça devrait faire
département j'ai énormément dans les
villes
les gens que je connais très bien
ce qu'ils en disent
c'est ma deuxième maison merci beaucoup
de là on peut aussi historique que le f
dream de martin luther à ses sketches et
la glace par oldelaf merci d'avoir été
avec merci merci merci en attendant
justement le concert de oldelaf demain
ce sera votre cas je crois bixente on
peut aller aussi faire les boutiques
c'est ça le lâche vitrine c'est le
dernier week-end des soldes
officiellement elle se termine le 30
janvier donc dimanche même si comme
chaque année on sait certaines boutiques
prolongeront le plaisir on vous citera
pas lieu précis pour pas faire trop pub
grégory mais dans les yvelines ya de
quoi faire en centres commerciaux et
boutiques de quartier au programme
également de ce week-end à rendez-vous
du côté de la commanderie saint quentin
en yvelines mais une lecture à deux voix
samedi 29 janvier à 20h30 deux artistes
deux femmes dominique reymond et
frédérique bruyas interpréteront une
lecture inédite spécialement créé pour
la commanderie elle regroupera des
passages de plusieurs oeuvres qu'elles
ont interprété ensemble depuis le début
de leur amitié née en 1997 il ya 24 ans
rendez vous donc à la commanderie de
saint quentin en yvelines pour accéder
au spectacle le prix normal est fixé à 9
euros ça nous arrive de temps en temps
bixente à présent vous nous parlez d'un
after work oui ces réunions
après le travail et autour d'un verre
comprend entre collègues ou entre
étudiants aussi ça arrive et bien du
côté du vésinet ils ont décidé que un
jeudi par mois ça serait plus qu'un ver
l'association vésinet live after works
organise des rendez vous musicaux tous
les mois dans le foyer du théâtre du
vésinet prochaines dates du coup jeudi 3
février avec tricia evy un rendez vous
pour les fans de jazz que jean baptiste
allemand ski président de l'association
nous présente celle interview express
[Musique]
l'initiative en fait de deux passionnés
de jazz
qui au gré de leurs déplacements un peu
dans le monde ont découvert le le fait
de se retrouver après le travail d'où
les afterworks
[Musique]
un jeudi par mois dans le foyer du
théâtre du vésinet on n'a que les gens à
partir de 19 heures quand on fait venir
des clubs dans ce club des groupes de
renommée mondiale
vous y rencontrer beaucoup de gens des
gens sympathiques des gens amoureux des
gens qui ont envie de faire partager un
sens tant de choses d'échangés somme est
un lieu d'échangé lieu de découverte un
lieu agréable et un lieu un petit peu
d'évasion par les temps qui courent on a
pas mal besoin
la prochaine date c'est tricia evy qui
vient avec un kart est donc piano
contrebasse batterie et chant bien
évidemment elle va reprendre des
standards du jazz du zouk de la pop
aussi un petit peu la chanson française
jazzifier
[Musique]
or à pierrick pédron le 10 mars pierrick
pédron s'arrête très grand saxophoniste
puisqu'il l'a été
il a eut reçu une victoire
aux awards du jazz il ya quelques années
il viendra lui en carte est également et
puis ensuite on aura le 7 avril emmanuel
bex qui vient là en trio avec son fils à
la batterie et un contrebassiste
et alors pour terminer bixente on se
rend du côté triel sur seine la ville
sera aux couleurs de l'asie frébault la
semaine prochaine ont fait l'année du
tigre le nouvel an chinois c'est
officiellement le mardi 1er février mais
à triel-sur-seine on va patienter le 5
pour fêter ça convenablement plein
week-end pour ce premier nouvel an
chinois organisé dans la commune les
festivités commenceront à 16 heures par
un défilé dans les rues commerçantes de
la ville au programme danse des lions et
parade des dragons de lumière et comme
point d'orgue de la soirée un spectacle
de danse et une démonstration d'arts
martiaux bon ce n'est qu'un avant goût
et pour en savoir plus n'hésitez pas à
retrouver l'émission 7,8 culture mardi
prochain célia gars tsongo parlera est
de ce nouvel an chinois à
triel-sur-seine merci bixente pour
toutes ces idées de sorties ainsi
grégory et c'est déjà la fin de ce sept
huit week-ends merci de nous avoir suivi
l'information lequel qui revient dès
lundi en direct à 18h et d'ici là passez
un très bon week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]